you are watching a clip from the john
perry channel
genetics and evolution
information theory has been used a lot
in in biology shannon as you know worked
for the bell telephone company and so he
was concerned with the economics of
information transfer so he wanted to
think of think of ways in which
information could be most economically
encoded and he came with the idea of the
bit of information as the fundamental
unit of information information for him
meant reduction of
uncertainty it was actually measured
as reduction of uncertainty and his
formula
measured it like that one of the things
that comes out of
shannon type mathematics is this idea
that
information as a commodity
is easily
translated into other media
so it doesn't matter
whether it's in the form of punch paper
tape or
little lips on um magnetic tape or a
little
um
noise morse code or little little noises
going down a wire
if if it's
in the same if it's translated from one
digital code to another then it can be
faithfully rendered at the other end
with a certain
possibility of
error
and
i very much like the idea i've been very
inspired by the idea of information as a
commodity which as you just described it
can be translated from one medium to
another and retains its value
retains its meaning
throughout all these different
translations
sharon was concerned with the
economics of information transfer such
that nothing is lost or little as
possible is lost that's different from
the semantics from actually what what
the information means which is a whole
separate subject
let's try and unpack this even more so
what is information in general
in your view and then what is
information
in genetics specifically
maybe maybe that could be helpful
well as i said shannon described it as
or measured it as reduction in
uncertainty so when it's when it's
transferred from one
place to another in in human terms
you you start with the idea that there's
a sender and a receiver
and
and the receiver doesn't know something
that the sender does know
so um shannon was
was aware that something like the sun
rose this morning contains much less
information than the sun did not rise
this morning because the receiver
already expects that the sun will rise
and therefore i mean the the reduction
of of uncertainty the surprise value
is is is less so um the one bit of
information is is
that which halves your uncertainty
um if you have something like um
uh if if if i turn up a card for an
ordinary pack of cards and i ask you to
guess
um the
um
the cut the color of the card your
uncertainty is is exactly
um
twofold it could be red or it could be
black so if i tell you it's black that's
one bit of information it's it's been
reduced by one
by what's been divided in in half
um if i tell you it's a
it's a heart
um that's two bits of information
because you don't know whether first
whether it's a color and secondly given
that given that it's red say whether it
could be a heart or a diamond so that's
how he measured information and you can
measure information exactly in the same
way
in the genetic code it being a
quaternary code rather than a binary
code it's a little bit more complicated
i have had on my show dr david fialo and
we were talking about you know what is
information in biology and he was
explaining that the base information in
biology is nucleotide sequences sequence
information is the thing that's being
communicated from parent to child
but that doesn't necessarily have any
sort of meaning to it right it could be
a random chain of of rna for example
claude shannon wasn't interested in
meaning he was just interested in how do
you transfer information from one thing
to another if you talk about this in
biological terms he's interested in
replication how do you get a system
going that can replicate a chain of rna
for example but in biology we also care
about meaning and what i mean by that is
that you know the the
specific sequences in our dna help us
better survive and reproduce
and
what you've so beautifully spent your
career explaining is really i guess you
could say is where that meaning comes
from this is what darwin explained
through the process of natural selection
as soon as you have a system capable of
replicating you can get darwinian
evolution
and just automatically
those sequences which happen to be
better at reproducing than others
end up becoming more common
in the population
and you get this explosion of
not just information but useful
information information that's useful
in the project of surviving and
reproducing it is very amazing and it
completely gives the lie to anybody to
the things you have to have a creator
uh to start these things off it really
does show quite an increase in
complexity increase in adaptive
efficiency
as the generations
go by
so that was just a clip for my
conversation with richard dawkins you
can see the whole thing there's a link
to that down below subscribe to this
channel if you enjoyed it
i upload clips pretty regularly talks
and conversations and presentations that
i've done on genetics and evolution and
i am gearing up to start doing weekly
videos again here that are completely
new completely fresh